we're so proud of you like thanks wild
not that we didn't ever imagine you're
gonna be the biggest star in the whole
world but like you're here what does it
feel like being out there and going yo
like this is my show everybody like
check this out
here i am
i used to watch you on tv when i was a
kid so this is nuts for me too like
that's great like this is all it's very
exciting anyway canadians are great but
um for me it's it's wild i mean the hall
h is like
the thing you hear about at comic-con
and the thing that everybody says like
oh my god have you been to hall age so
to be able to like
present the trailer which we hadn't even
seen yet watch it with the fans was nuts
it's wild
now i talked to tim roth a while ago and
he just was glowing about working with
you and your performance what's it been
like to be able to you know to play off
of these incredible actors and maybe not
just do everything yourself literally
yes right
right yeah yeah to have scene partners
yeah it's awesome um
yeah tim tim and like benedict and mark
like these are people who have like such
a legacy of work not only in the mcu but
just also like as actors so it's such a
joy to get to play opposite them and and
i think what's really fun about this
show is that it takes those known
characters and it flips them on their
head so they're suddenly in a tone
that's completely different and like
really stretches their character and so
i get to experience that with them and
yeah it's really playful and really fun
dude we're so excited congratulations